hello Guardians you may have noticed
fellow players bouncing around the farm
like crazy Jackrabbits and you have no
idea how they're doing that that's good
because we're here to help you find the
secret scouting mission and scannable
story beats so start at the landing pad
on this side of town leap onto the
rooftop to your left and run across the
electrical wire
then back this should pop the
commander's blessing in which you'll
start to glow blue and run slash leap
faster
[Music]
next go to the end of that building and
run across the adjacent wire to the
windmill
[Music]
run back and forth on the windmill until
you get the wheel boost finally run back
across town to the fire pit by the
landing area next to the big lake
[Music]
light that bonfire and you'll turn red
you now have a set amount of time to do
the scouting mission involving jumping
through blue lights around the map when
you've completed that I'd highly
recommend using your new jumping powers
to find in scan story elements hidden
around the farm
they look like sacks of supplies with a
sniper rifle propped up against them and
a pair of binoculars on top if you want
to know where they are I'll show you
that at the end of this video we're just
getting started with destiny too so make
sure to give us the old thumbs up and
subscribe for more as we all get raid
ready we can't wait to play with you all
let's get to it
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
devran spent years defending the city
from places just like this along the
wall I can see why he found this spot
comforting
[Music]
if Hawthorne hadn't been out there in
the wilds on the lookout for people
escaping the city well I'm glad we met
her who knows where we'd be now
[Music]
look at this I've heard some of the
civilians talk about settling down out
here once the fighting stops I'm not
sure that's such a good idea but you
can't argue with the view
I don't have training for that
a shard of the traveler I can't find any
record of why it's here or how it got
here we're a long way from the city you
know I want to believe it's here for a
reason for us